bonsoir à tous merci de votre attention
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
jeudi
dominés bien sûr par cette attaque
terroriste de grande envergure à londres
qui a fait des dizaines de morts et des
centaines de blessés dans le nord de la
ville quatre explosions trois dans le
métro une dans un bus les attentats
portent semble-t-il la marque d'al qaïda
est une revendication est analysée par
les services de renseignement ce soir la
capitale britannique vit toujours au
ralenti une partie du centre ville est
bouclé par la police
l'attaqué était conçu pour avoir un
impact maximum puisque le monde entier a
les yeux tournés vers la grande-bretagne
où tony blair accueille le g8
jacques chirac georges bush et les
autres chefs d'état et de gouvernement
expriment leur horreur et leur
détermination à ne pas céder devant le
terrorisme la france comme plusieurs
autres pays à renforcer les mesures de
sécurité
le plan vigipirate est relevé au niveau
rouge que sait-on des groupes
terroristes en europe
y at il une menace en france question
que nous poserons au ministre de
l'intérieur nicolas sarkozy bon soir et
à ton sort ces explosions ont bel et
bien sûr le choix de londres comme ville
olympique la délégation française
revenue aujourd'hui de singapour
s'associer à la douleur les anglais nous
sommes tous des londoniens a lancé
bertrand delanoë autre actualité de
cette journée à l'heure où les incendies
au parc
un pyromane a été condamné à quatre ans
de prison ferme dans le var il s'agit
d'un ancien sapeur-pompier volontaire
enfin le tour de france étape marquée
par une chute collective sur une route
glissante de lorraine victoire de
vicques
un bernucci lance armstrong conserve le
maillot jaune
londres est donc passé en quelques
heures de la joie au cauchemar c'était
un peu avant 9h ce matin à l'heure de
pointe donc que la première explosion a
retenti dans le métro trois autres ont
suivi le récit de cette matinée tirée
curtet arnauld miguet dans les mêmes
ambulance à la fois les blessés pouvoir
encore marcher et des cas les plus
désespérés
les premiers blessés ont été soignés sur
les quais ou sur les trottoirs à la
sortie des stations de métro
mais personne au tout début ne comprend
ce qui arrive
la première explosion a provoqué une
coupure d'électricité générale
les passagers vont rester une trentaine
de minutes dans les rames stoppée sans
information en plusieurs endroits
les tunnels s'emplissent de fumée
certains cas seront les vitres à mains
nues les gens commençaient à crier parce
qu'il y avait une odeur de brûlé
tout le monde s'est dit qu'on allait
mourir les gens ont commencé à chanter
des prières à prier dieu ils ont paniqué
on a cassé les fenêtres du métro avec
nos mains de manière à avoir de
l'oxygène
mais très vite en regagnant la surface
il découvre les blessés les plus valides
ceux qui ont pu s'extraire seuls des
tunnels ce que j'ai vu c'est une lumière
jaune
8 je n'ai plus rien vu tout à coup les
vitres ont explosé
j'ai été touché au visage j'ai été
plaqué au sol
quelle a été votre première réaction
j'ai bien cru que j'étais mort
le fsi noir tout a été planifié la
première bombe explose à une heure de
grande affluence
8h51 quasiment sur la même ligne deux
autres bombes
en tout quatre déflagration en 56
minutes
la dernière dans ce bus impérial ouf il
a été complètement soufflé la police ne
parvient pas à établir ici le nombre de
victimes
elle se demande si un kamikaze n'était
pas à bord
ce jeune français vivant à londres
s'apprêtaient à monter dans l'autobus le
bus 30
en fait tout simplement et je les rater
il est passé devant moi
puis j'ai pris un autre bus en fait
qu'ils allaient faire livrer cause toute
la station de métro qui a explosé aussi
donc je me suis descendu du bus j'ai
commencé à marcher vers l'autre station
holgate qui a explosé aussi donc c'est
comme ça pour scotland yard enquête
commence
les terroristes ont soigneusement choisi
leur cible les quatre attentats ont
touché la capitale britannique en son
coeur
le bilan officiel est de 37 morts et 700
blessés mais d'après les témoins il
serait plus lourd
plusieurs heures après les ambulances
sillonnaient toujours les rues de la
capitale britannique karine comazzi
sophie meyer hôpital royal de londres
les premiers blessés arrivent et délivre
péniblement leurs premiers témoignages
j'ai pensé qu'on avait heurté un train
qu'il y avait une collision
parce que nous étions quand même en un
seul morceau il n'y avait pas d'
incendies
toutes les vitres avaient explosé la
tôle était pliée à l'intérieur du wagon
on a ressenti un gros impact mais sur le
coup on n'a pas du tout pensé que ça
pouvait être un attentat terroriste
déjà les sauveteurs repartent vers les
stations de métro celle-ci holgate
ressemble à un hôpital de campagne
les ambulances charge des blessés par
dizaines station et djouher sur le
trottoir un jeune homme encore choqués
on est monté dans le train et quelques
secondes après ça a explosé
il a commencé à y avoir de la fumée
partout j'étais dans le wagon de tête
avec des gens gravement blessés
on m'a dit qu'à l'arrière il y avait des
gens dans un état bien pire des flots de
passagers à gars sortent du métro comme
on sort d'un cauchemar
je ne sais pas ce qui se passait et puis
tout à coup on a été plongée dans le
noir après l'explosion ça hurlait
partout le conducteur est sorti du wagon
nous allons très une lumière rouge on a
eu peur on pensait enfin moi je pensais
qu'ils étaient déjà mortes
j'ai une vision d' incendies nous a fait
remonter le quai et je ne savais pas ce
qu'il se passait vous en savez
certainement plus que moi il y avait des
gens vraiment très blessé je l'ait
vraiment échappé belle certains s'en
tire avec quelques contusions beaucoup
sont grièvement blessés plusieurs
dizaines ils laisseront leur vie
le hasard d'avoir pris le métro à matane
attentat ce soir londres ressemble à une
ville fantôme une partie du centre-ville
est fermé aux voitures les transports
sont paralysés beaucoup de commerces ont
baissé leurs rideaux
frédéric rostaing mattia selon la mère
vient d'être donné
les policiers sont extrêmement tendues
toutes sirènes hurlantes ambulances et
voitures de police convergent sur mon
vieux lourd explosion on ne parle pas
encore pour l'instant d'attentats débris
de toutes les stations du métro de
londres son père mais sans aucune
explication
pour beaucoup la marche à pied devient
le seul moyen de transport les taxes ils
ont pris d'assaut et liane foly les gens
sont perdus cherche un taxi la thèse de
l'attentât se précise c'est quand même
une saturation du réseau des portables
les files d'attentes devant les cabines
téléphoniques s'allonge
il ya beaucoup de coups de fil par
contre de nos de la france qui essaient
de se renseigner parce qu'il se
demandait nous est d'arriver
les vendeurs de journaux font recette et
à la télévision les messages de la
police sont sans équivoque la seule
chose que nous recommandons à la
population ce ne devait pas bouger
si vous êtes à la maison rester à la
maison si vous êtes au travail rester au
travail tous taiwo en fin d'après-midi
le métro est toujours fermé au public
car il faut vérifier station par station
qu'aucun autre engin n'est susceptible
d'exploser
tout le réseau du métro de londres est
passée au peigne fin pour s'assurer
qu'il n'ya vu d'engins explosifs et les
bus ne sont plus en circulation pour
votre foyer
alors les londoniens qui dans l'ensemble
n'ont pas versé dans la panique regagne
comme ils peuvent leur domicile c'est à
pied que beaucoup ont décidé de faire le
trajet innombrables bouchons à la sortie
de la capitale et en fin d'après midi
une nouvelle alerte à la station
victoria qui n'a pas contribué à
rassurer la population londonienne
évidemment très marqué par ce jeudi noir
et en direct de londres
on retrouve laurent boussier bonsoir
l'euro on s'attend donc un bilan qui va
sans doute dépassé les chiffres actuels
oui absolument tout état de cause le
bilan actuel va augmenter ne serait ce
que parce que les victimes de l'attentât
dans le bus à russell scolaires n'ont
pas encore été toutes prises en compte
la police ne veut pas donner le chiffre
exact mais ce que l'on sait de manière
de sources non officielles mais
concordance et qu'elle serait aux
membres de 10 avec éventuellement
l'implication d'un terroriste alors on
le choc a été très rude 1 mais on est
surpris en regardant les images par le
flegme et des britanniques
écoutez d'abord les londoniens savait
depuis longtemps que leurs vives était
une cible potentielle pour les
terroristes
et puis d'autre part les services de
sécurité la police les pompiers et les
ambulances avaient fait des exercices
l'année dernière d' alerte à la bombe et
d' alerte chimique justement dans le
métro des services de sécurité qui
aujourd'hui ont parfaitement réagi tout
et s'est passée relativement dans le
dans le calme évidemment malgré quelques
scènes de panique
et puis de toute façon vous savez les
britanniques sont assez flegmatique et
ils ne veulent absolument pas que les
terroristes leur guide leur manière de
vivre et leur manière de penser
merci laurent vous retrouvera tout à
l'heure un choc aussi en tout cas pour
tony blair le chef du gouvernement qui
recevait le g 8 en écosse est apparu
très ému pour sa première déclaration
très déterminés aussi il a quitté le
sommet quelques heures pour se rendre
sur place
on les écoute ainsi que le maire de
londres ken livingstone que les
responsables de ces actes barbares sache
bien que notre détermination à défendre
nos valeurs et notre mode de vie
parise est plus grande
est-ce que leur détermination à semer la
mort et la destruction chez les
innocents pour imposer leur extrémisme
au moods of the world
l'explosion cette attaque terroriste ne
visait pas l'effort et les puissants le
président ou les premiers ministres
elles visaient les londoniens ordinaire
noir et blanc musulmans comme chrétiens
hindous juifs vieux et jeunes on à tuer
pour tuer les britanniques et les
londoniens en particulier sont donc
passés de l'euphorie olympique à
l'horreur du terrorisme les banderoles
londres 2012 n'ont pas encore été rangée
on l'aperçoit sur cette vue aérienne
la stupeur n'en a été que plus grande
envoyés spéciaux maryse burgot connolly
la fierté le bonheur des anglais hier
soir sur trafalgar square
le même endroit cet après midi
étrangement silencieux et drapeau des
jeux olympiques sont évidemment toujours
là mais la fête n'est plus dans les
esprits
les gros titres de la presse sur la
victoire de londres appartiennent
désormais au passé
c'est de terreur que l'on parle ce soir
comment peut-on passer d'un tel
sentiment de joie hier assez brutale
descente aux enfers
autour de trafalgar des milliers de
londoniens marche puisqu'il n'y a plus
de transports en commun
étrange ambiance en ce lendemain de fête
vous vous souvenez lorsque les tours se
sont effondrées à new york
on voyait ces images de gens qui
quittaient la ville eh bien c'est la
même chose ici
l'inquiétude est sur tous les visages
mais le positivisme têtu des anglais est
déjà de retour dans les pubs lé la bière
n'est pas festif comme elle le fut
d'hier soir elles se partagent
d'ailleurs entre anglais et les
questions d'une équipe de télévision
française ne sont pas spécialement les
bienvenus aucun commentaire j'aimerais
garder mon point de vue pas tout seul
je suis choqué dégoûté hier c'était un
beau jour aujourd'hui c'est un jour très
triste ce soir londres est en deuil
elle organisera les jeux en 2012 mais
dans les esprits
ils seront à jamais associé à ses
attentes à londres s'apprêtait à
organiser de nombreuses manifestations
pour fêter sa victoire après l'obtention
des jeux olympiques de 2012
toutes ces festivités ont bien entendu
était suspendu
et cette douleur et cette incrédulité
aussi tous les dirigeants de la planète
réunis à gleneagles en écosse pour le g8
l'ont ressentie aussi l'émotion était
palpable et la solidarité sans faille
sur place véronique syntonisent francis
forget il est 13 heures 10 les chefs
d'état et de gouvernement des nations
les plus puissantes du monde
les représentants des grands pays
émergents font bloc autour de tony blair
venue à ce sommet avec de profonds
désaccords ils sont à cet instant unis
comme jamais ce n'est pas un attentat
contre un pays en particulier mais
contre toutes les nations et tous les
peuples civilisés partout dans le monde
tous affichent une extrême gravité c'est
l'image historique d'un pack soudé par
la volonté de lutter ensemble contre le
terrorisme
la nouvelle d'une explosion dans le
métro à londres est tombé ce matin au
château de gleneagles au moment précis
où tony blair accueillir ses hôtes du g8
il les informe attentat ou accident on
ne sait pas encore mais dès le début de
la réunion on apprend les explosions
dans les bus il n'y a alors plus de
doute
solidarité compassion détermination les
déclarations s'enchaînent ces acteurs
sont inqualifiables
cette mépris à l'égard de la vie humaine
est quelque chose que nous devons
combattre avec une fermeté sans cesse
accrue et toujours plus solidaire
le président américain qui depuis les
attentats du 11 septembre a déclaré une
guerre totale à al qaïda s'engage
solennellement un ailleurs on ne cédera
pas à ces gens un cédera pas aux
terroristes
on les trouvera et on les traduire en
justice après le départ de tony blair à
londres les chefs d'état ont continué à
travailler comme pour prouver que le
terrorisme n'avait réussi qu'à renforcer
leur solidarité et jack straw le
ministre des affaires étrangères a pris
la présidence de la réunion
en attendant le retour de tony blair
bonsoir thierry thulliez vous suivez
vous aussi ce sommet ça fait quelques
années que vous avez l'habitude des
grandes réunions mais vous avez senti
cette fois une unité très forte devant
l'événement
oui incontestablement il ya une image je
crois qu'il faut retenue
de cette journée si particulière à
gleneagles c'est cette fameuse photo de
famille qui a pour une fois j'allais
dire bien porté son nom photo très
impressionnante à la mesure du choc et
de la stupéfaction qui a saisi les
autres de ce sommet songez george bush
et jacques chirac côte à côte en cadrant
tony blair pendant sa déclaration ou
bien encore le brésilien lula le chinois
hu jintao côtoyant le russe vladimir
poutine tous sont unis a rassemblé
derrière tony blair pour dire évidemment
non à la menace terroriste est
d'ailleurs sur le fond tony blair
évidemment réitérer et s'est fait le
porte parole de ses collègues étrangers
pour réitérer évidemment que la lutte
contre le terrorisme
il ira jusqu'à son terme avec une
victoire des démocraties et des pays
donc présent à ce g8
une dernière chose évidemment david vous
imaginez on attend ici le retour de tony
blair qui devrait donc présidé comme
prévu le dîner de cette soirée est au
menu évidemment il y aura le terrorisme
qui n'avait pas été prévue mais le
l'ordre du jour de cette soirée est
bousculé évidemment depuis ce matin
merci thierry alors question maintenant
pourquoi la grande bretagne at elle été
visée en fait depuis longtemps les
dirigeants anglais redouter un attentat
et plus encore peut-être depuis quelques
mois
voici pourquoi explications amaury
guibert arnauld miguet la police avait
toujours un oeil sur lui
mais le laisser faire devant la mosquée
de finsbury park à londres l'imam
radical abou hamza parlait sans retenue
attaque en règle contre l'occident les
mécréants
ce qui lui vaut aujourd'hui d'être en
prison en attendant son procès de non
croyants sont des espions même s'ils ne
font rien si les musulmans ne peuvent
pas les réduire à l'esclavagé ou les
vendre sur un marché alors tuer les
derrière ce discours londres et la
grande bretagne sont devenu une plaque
tournante des activistes islamistes en
europe une étape pour les candidats au
djihad
en général ce qu'ils font à londres
c'est se forme et idéologiquement
à prendre un certain nombre de acquérir
un certain nombre de savoir en terme de
savoir religieux et sur le djihad et
ensuite pouvoir ensuite voyager aller
sur les terrains du djihad et se former
militairement cette fois exemple concret
dans cette maison de manchester où est
passé un français morts dans un attentat
suicide en irak
un homme formé en bosnie en afghanistan
d'une discrétion absolue lorsqu'il était
en angleterre son ancien colocataire dit
se souvenir d'un bon musulman qui allait
régulièrement à la mosquée mais sans
plus pas un extrémiste en tout cas et il
est parfaitement évident que le pays
doit faire face aujourd'hui à des
menaces terroristes qu'il n'y avait
jamais connu auparavant accusé de
laxisme par bon nombre de ses
partenaires la grande bretagne est
contrainte de réagir après le 11
septembre 2001 des lois antiterroristes
plus sévères et des opérations de police
en série
coup sur coup les services secrets
neutralise un projet d'attentât chimique
démantèle un commando qui voulaient
attaquer un aéroport londonien ou
arrêtent le chef d'al-qaïda en
grande-bretagne des succès mais aussi
une prise de conscience le pays est une
cible comme le reconnaît le maire de
londres
il ya un an et demi et webp serait
miraculeux compte tenu des moyens mis en
oeuvre par les terroristes et compte
tenu du fait que certains sont prêts à y
laisser leur vie qu'ils n'y parviennent
pas un jour à londres alors le pays
s'est préparé au pire il y a un an et
demi un attentat chimiques étaient
simulées dans le quartier de la city à
londres à l'époque
80 % des britanniques étaient persuadés
que leur pays serait frappé un jour ou
l'autre par le terrorisme et puis il
faut rappeler que la grande bretagne est
l'alliée numéro un des états unis en
irak où elle a 8000 hommes sur place à
londres on retrouve laurent boussier
laurent une revendication a été diffusée
sur internet a dressé aussi un ministre
allemand de quoi s'agit-il
est-elle prise au sérieux et le décès
d'une revendication fait par un groupe
jusqu'alors inconnu qui s'appelle al
qaeda djihad en europe
alors je ne sais pas si cette
revendiquer ce devrait être
revendications là en particulier prise
au sérieux par la police mais ce qui est
sûr en tout cas c'est que toutes les
revendications venant de groupes
islamiques vont être étudiées avec
énormément d'attention par la police et
les services de sécurité britanniques
il y a quelques semaines la police et
ces mêmes services de sécurité
avait effectué plusieurs coups de filet
dans les milieux islamistes londonien
évidemment visiblement ceux qui ont
perpétré les attentats d'aujourd'hui on
sont passés au travers des mailles de ce
filet j'ai contacté il ya quelques
quelques instants des membres d'unités
antiterroristes
ils m'ont confirmé que pour préparer ce
type d'attentât avec ce type de
professionnalisme les attentats qui ont
lieu aujourd'hui
il fallait entre quatre et six mois
voyez le coup de filet et il ya quelques
semaines
ceux là sont passés au travers vous
restez avec nous lors on vous retrouvera
sans doute à la fin de ce journal
le terrorisme est donc de retour au
coeur de l'europe difficile de ne pas
faire le rapprochement avec l'attentât
commis en espagne il ya 16 mois et qui
avaient fait 191 morts
comme à madrid ce sont les transports
publics qui ont été visés comme à madrid
il ya eu plusieurs explosions presque
simultanées florence boucle en gare
d'atocha ce 11 mars 2004 plusieurs
explosions retentissent il est tôt et
comme dans le métro de londres
aujourd'hui des centaines de voyageurs
se rendant à leur travail
le bilan est terrible près de 200 morts
et 1900 blessés dix bombes ont explosé
dans quatre trains de banlieue à
destination de la gare principale de
madrid
le tout dans un laps de temps très court
comme à londres ce matin ou quatre
attentats ont frappé les transports
publics
trois dans le métro un dans un bus à
double étage à madrid dans un sac
les enquêteurs retrouvent une bombe qui
n'a pas explosé et dans cette
fourgonnette
le jour même de l'attentât des
empreintes celle de jamel ou gamme 31
ans arrêté le 19 mars
ce responsable d'al qaïda aurait fourni
les portables qui ont servi à déclencher
les bombes à distance
en tout le commando terroriste compte au
moins une trentaine d'hommes mais trois
semaines après les attentats
cerné par la police sept d'entre eux se
suicide à l'explosif dans leur
appartement de leganés près de madrid
depuis vingt-deux terroristes sont en
détention provisoire
parmi eux mohamed l'égyptien cerveau
présumé des attentats de madrid
arrêté en italie extradé en espoirs dans
cette nébuleuse figurent aussi abu darda
incarcéré depuis novembre 2001 à madrid
il a comparu en avril dernier pour sa
participation supposée aux attentats du
world trade center mais du fond de sa
prison il aurait pu aussi jouer un rôle
dans ce de madrid
le procès des auteurs présumés des
attentats on n'est ce pas
on devrait avoir lieu début 2006
quelques heures après l annonce de ces
attentats est un peu partout en europe
les mesures de sécurité ont été
renforcées en france le plan vigipirate
a été relevé au niveau rouge
zine dine boudaoud daniel lévy à paris
le drapeau britannique l'union jack
flotte à nîmes à l'ambassade du royaume
uni est en deuil
sa protection et renforcer des soldats
et des policiers stationnent devant
l'édifice
la france a renforcé son dispositif
vigipirate
j'ai décidé d'élever immédiatement le
plan vigipirate du niveau orange au
niveau rouge
la phase rouge de vigipirate prévoit des
contrôles aléatoires d'accès au train
des patrouilles dans les tgv et des
restrictions de l'espace aérien
c'est le troisième niveau d'une échelle
de risque qui en comporte quatre dans
chacune des gares parisiennes comme ici
gare du nord une quarantaine de
policiers et militaires patrouillent des
consignes de sécurité maximum ont été
données les contrôles des passagers et
de leurs bagages sont drastiques comme
dans le métro
la sncf annonce un renforcement de la
vigilance sur les grandes lignes ou
celle de banlieue pas de crainte ou de
panique sur les visages des usagers
d'abord si c'est quelque chose qu'on
pourra pas faire grand chose on va pas
faire grand chose donc des tracts palais
et nous constatons et les français
comptent sur vous la ministre de la
défense est venu encourager ses troupes
mobilisées par le plan de vigilance
anti-terroriste
plusieurs unités de l'armée qui était au
repos ont été rappelés à roissy les vols
vers les états unis et la grande
bretagne environ 90 par jour font
l'objet d'une surveillance étroite
un contrôle accrus des bagages est plus
serré des passagers est prévu le
renforcement de la sécurité concernent
les sites sensibles de la capitale
mais aussi ceux de province comme prévu
le ministre de l'intérieur nicolas
sarkozy est avec nous sur ce plateau
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
juste avant de vous entendre quelques
éléments sur ce qu'on appelle
traditionnellement la nébuleuse al qaïda
cet attentat relance les interrogations
sur la présence de cellules terroristes
en europe on a appris aussi que le
groupe
avait revendiqué l'assassinât de
l'ambassadeur d'égypte en irak enlevés
il ya quelques jours audrey goutard
bruno vignais les bombes explosent à
londres au même moment ce diplomate
égyptien a enlevé samedi à bagdad dans
sa voiture est exécuté deux actions
simultanées revendiqué par al qaïda
une véritable stratégie terroriste de la
part de l'organisation
la stratégie d'al qaïda ses frappes et
provoquer le maximum de victimes
perturbé les économies occidentales et
montrer à ses partisans que al-qaïda
existe toujours pour pouvoir les motiver
et poursuivre les recrutements une
guerre sans répit
en fait al qaïda poursuit un processus
de terreur qui n'a jamais cessé depuis
l'attentât de madrid en 2004
la preuve des centaines
d'interpellations d'islamistes en france
et partout en europe depuis des années
des combattants prêts à l'action et qui
annoncent régulièrement leur volonté
d'en découdre avec les pays qui ont
envoyé des troupes en irak d action
terroriste planifiée très longtemps à
l'avant ce ne sont pas des attentats
spontané il ya certainement un décideur
qui ad ce qui a mis au point cette
opération qui a demandé plusieurs mois
de préparation qui a demandé
certainement tête 20 30 personnes pour
pour préparer cet attentat d'autres
terroristes seraient déjà prêts à
l'action
les autorités françaises et leurs
homologues européens se préparent donc à
toute éventualité
l'italie d'ailleurs vient d'annoncer
officiellement qu'elle savait que son
pays était une cible d'al qaïda
nicolas sarkozy a d'abord est-ce que
vous avez des informations sur cet
attentat en grande-bretagne jugé deux
fois aujourd'hui ministre intérieur
britannique d'où la dernière fois il ya
une demi heure
il m'a indiqué que le bilan provisoire
c'était 50 morts 300 blessés dont 50
très grave qu'il y avait eu quatre
explosions trois dans le métro une dans
un autobus que celle ci avait été d'une
violence considérable puisque le toit du
métro s'est effondré il m'a précisé que
la scène du crime était très difficile à
reconstituer du fait des dégâts qui
avait été provoqué par le souffle
l'explosion lé sentiment dominant des
britanniques est peut-être le vôtre fort
de toutes les informations dont vous
disposez sur l'origine de cet attentat
on va d'abord les britanniques indiqué
qu'ils étaient tous mobilisés qu'il
recherchait des renseignements des
pistes pour retrouver cette bande de
criminels parce que c'est bien de ça
dont il s'agit
les applis terroriste est encore trop
indulgent parce que ça voudrait dire
qu'ils me des logis derrière n'y a pas
d'idéologie sont des assassins qui ne
respectent rien ni personne et la piste
al qaïda est privilégiée et m'a indiqué
qu'il pensait que c'était la piste
al-qaïda même s'il n'en avait pas
d'élément il m'a également indiqué qu'à
sa connaissance en est sûr il n'y avait
pas eu des coups de bombes humaines
enfin le kamikaze kamikaze à sa
connaissance mais tac des choses j'ai
moi même décidé d'envoyer cinq
fonctionnaires de police immédiatement
par avion spécial pour aller sur place
recueillir tous les éléments possibles
pour que nous en tirions le plus
rapidement possible un certain nombre de
conclusions
car enfin ce qui s'est passé à new york
ce qui s'est passé à madrid ce qui s'est
passé à londres aujourd'hui qui nous
disons bien sûr toute notre solidarité
notre compassion se passe dans des
démocraties
la france est une démocratie y at il une
menace terroriste en france aujourd'hui
il n'est forte qu'il ya quelques mois et
billard il n'y a pas une menace précise
terroristes mais nous prenons toutes ces
affaires extrêmement au sérieux car nous
savons parfaitement que des terroristes
pourraient avoir la volonté de frapper
en france ils ont déjà frappé par le
passé donc nous considérons en état de
vigilance absolument maximum tous les
services sont mobilisés notamment les
services de renseignement parce que
qu'est ce qui compte c'est de pouvoir
attraper ces gens avant qu'ils agissent
rapidité d'exécution pour nos capitales
ont sur les deux ou trois dernières
années il ya eu plusieurs équipes qui
ont été arrêtés en france
l'équipe qu'on appelait celle de romain
vide les derniers les sept de limoges et
de montpellier
nous savons qu'ils savaient faire des
explosifs qu'ils savaient fabriquer des
éléments pour déclencher ses explosifs
distance et que par conséquent on ne
peut pas considérer que nous sommes à
l'abri
ces groupes-là avait des projets
terroristes ces groupes veut écouter
quand on a des recettes pour constituer
des explosifs quand on trouve chez eux
des éléments pour constituer les
explosifs on peut penser qu'il ne
plaisante pas et par conséquent pour
nous la menace existe
cette menace est plus forte aujourd'hui
qu'il ya quelques mois est ce qu'il ya
aujourd'hui des groupes en france des
groupes dormant pour reprendre un
langage couramment utilisés qu'ils
seraient prêts à passer à l'action
alors qu'est ce qu'on constate pas ce
qu'il faut à la fois donné dans une
démocratie toutes les informations parce
que la démocratie c'est la transparence
et qu'on n'a rien à cacher aux citoyens
et en même temps il faut pas provoquer
de phénomènes de panique car c'est
exactement ce que souhaite cette bande
d'assassins
alors qu'est ce qu'on constate on
constate plusieurs phénomènes
d'abord du côté du terrorisme algérienne
gspc qui a fait allégeance à la mouvance
al qaïda on a découvert avec beaucoup
d'eux de crainte que certains français
illuminé était passé par l'irak est
inquiétante un foyer et que la mouvance
al qaïda ce qu'elle voulait déstabiliser
c'étaient les démocraties l'ennemi c'est
la démocratie sont les droits de l'homme
c'est la liberté
et tout ceci crée un terreau dont notre
pays n'est malheureusement pas absents
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
beaucoup renforcé les services de
renseignement parce que l'action
préventive partout en france puisque les
dernières arrestations ont lieu à
montpellier et à limoges
d'autres avaient eu à relever cette
action préventive c'est encore la
meilleure façon de prévenir le risque et
si le niveau rouge
si le plan vigipirate a été relevé au
niveau rouge c'est de la précaution ou
c'est en réponse à une menace précise
bon si vous voulez on en a parlé avec le
premier ministre
une heure après les événements s'il ne
mettons pas le plan vigipirate au niveau
rouge alors qu'il ya au moins 50 morts
dans des actes terroristes à londres
quand est-ce qu'on mettra
dans ce mouvement de vigipirate avait
deux choses c'est d'abord militaire en
deux jours qui vont venir sur le terrain
renforcé les équipes de la police et de
la gendarmerie mais c'est aussi une
façon de dire aux français que chacun
d'entre eux dont les contacts de la
sécurité de l'autre que sans panique
sans changer ses habitudes faut être
vigilant une dernière joueurs attention
une dernière chose nicholas apprécier ce
que vous savez si parmi les 50 morts
britanniques et les centaines de blessés
il ya des français écoutez je vous le
dit prudemment parce que je collecte des
informations à ma connaissance il y
aurait sous réserve
deux françaises blessés ce sont les
derniers éléments que j'ai eus je vous
les donne pour ce que je les tiens c'est
à dire les communications sont
extrêmement difficiles et demain on
pourra faire un point plus précis
quand les policiers que nous avons
envoyé à londres reviendront et que nos
amis britanniques auront eux mêmes plus
de renseignements sur ce drame qui vient
de se passer chez eux merci monsieur le
ministre d'avoir répondu à nos questions
toute la journée la sncf a déconseillé
aux voyageurs de se rendre en grande
bretagne en cette période de départ en
vacances l'atmosphère était évidemment
un peu particulière à lille ou à la gare
du nord à paris
anne-sophie chamiers lecomte marianne
masse romain clément
de marché aujourd'hui
en cas de nécessité absolue
différer son départ ou renoncer à partir
les consignes de la sncf sont claires
pourtant à la gare du nord à
l'embarquement de l'eurostar les
voyageurs sont là sur la plate forme
latente se prolonge jusqu'à deux heures
sans inquiétude perceptible plutôt du
fatalisme qu'il ya autant de risques les
demandes une g de riz 7 6
je suis là-bas j'habite là bas c'est là
bas ma vie c'est là bas ma place pour
j'ai pas le choix
vous avez commises aux fraises anglais
comme aguer non ils ont tenu le coup
dans la gare en milieu d'après midi
certains ignorent encore que londres a
subi des attentats ces deux jeunes
anglais s'apprêtait à rentrer dans leur
pays
il leur faudra de longues minutes pour
réaliser dans l'autre garros tard celle
de lille des affichettes préviennent les
voyageurs qu'à londres
ils ne trouveront ni bus ni métro la
plupart décide de partir quand même
certains renoncent dans l'essai
les secours étaient déjà en feu à leur
bord et s'il ya des possibilités de
remboursement
la sncf attend de voir demain le nombre
de voyageurs au départ pour londres afin
de mesurer l'impact réel des attentats
sur le trafic
bonsoir agnès molinier vous êtes en
direct de la gare du nord peut-on parler
de retour à la normale se soient écoutés
david c'est en tout cas ce qu'annonce la
sncf la vente des billets au guichet
redevenue normale depuis plusieurs
heures après avoir été interrompue en
début d'après midi et il n'y aurait plus
de retards des eurostar en provenance de
londres depuis environ 18 heures or on
l'a vu dans le reportage à l'instant il
ya eu beaucoup de perturbations
aujourd'hui deux trains ou même
carrément étaient annulés entre
bruxelles et londres
parce que les personnels d'eurostar
basée dans la capitale britannique
n'arrivait pas à rallier la gare de
waterloo pour prendre leur service
et c'est d'ailleurs essentiellement pour
ne pas ajouter à cette paralysie pour ne
pas en rajouter que la compagnie
eurostar dissuader on l'a vu aussi les
passagers de partir aujourd'hui plutôt
que pour de réelles raisons de sécurité
puisque la société eurotunnel a fait
savoir qu'il n'y avait pas de menace
particulière dans le tunnel sous la
manche
en revanche malgré tout la sécurité a
été renforcée à la gare du nord ici à
paris la présence policière a été doublé
allait passer de 30 à 60
et puis des militaires et des gendarmes
mobiles sont arrivés ce soir merci agnès
pour ces dernières précisions
et puis si vous avez de la famille ou
des proches à londres et bien le
ministère des affaires étrangères a mis
en place une cellule de crise et deux
numéros d'appels sont à votre
disposition vous les découvrez le 01 45
50 34 60 et le 0 800 174 174
ces explosions en deuil bien sûr le
choix de londres comme ville olympique
la délégation française revenue
aujourd'hui de singapour s'associe à la
douleur des anglais anouk burel
jean-marc new look
ils sont partis déçus de la défaite ils
reviennent choqué par les attentats le
commandant de bord a informé l'équipe en
plein vol messieurs dames vous en doutez
tout de suite on a pensé aux londoniens
aux victimes aux familles des blessés on
est de tout coeur vraiment de tout coeur
avec vraiment de tout faire avec
on a pris déjà un premier coup sur la
tête hier on voit que la trivalle de
pierre de la vie reprend reprend ses
droits je dirais sur l'actualité et qu'
il m'a relaxé ex un désastre c'est tout
le monde devrait se passer bien sûr ça
nous a choqués tout de suite on se dit
mon dieu si si si on a vu l'élection
pour nous hier peut-être ça sera pareil
on peut tout imaginer
thierry labric de fête de fin
cette sportive en tout cas je parle sur
le plan
non dans les terres qui d'un seul coup
il ya des choses qui coupent tout ça et
avec
terrible choc pourquoi pourquoi on n'est
pas l'abri donc après après madrid a
pris casablanca après sa terrible
bertrand delanoë étaient venus les
accueillir à l'aéroport
tous repartent amer et solidaire avec
les anglais bertrand delanoë qui était
arrivé un peu plus tôt dans la journée à
l'aéroport du bourget on écoute le maire
de paris compétitions olympiques c'est
dérisoire par rapport à des attentats
dans une ville qui s'en prennent à des
innocents et de ce point de vue là il
n'y a pas d'ambiguïté
nous sommes tous de soins du lalande au
mien je ne suis pas tout à fait
londonien olympiques mais par rapport à
cette épreuve qui est imposé au peuple
de londres aujourd'hui à travers les
attentats je suis totalement totalement
dans la solidarité l'affection même
voilà oubliez donc pour l'instant
l'amertume exprimé hier après l'échec de
la candidature de paris en revanche on
le disait dès hier soir beaucoup des
infrastructures prévues pour les jeux
olympiques en france devrait être
maintenue peut-être pas avec le même
calendrier
daniel wolfromm nathalie gallet leur
père olympique des batignolles à bien
triste mine aujourd'hui planté tout seul
devant le plus grand terrain disponible
de la région parisienne 45 hectares d'un
seul tenant
c'est ici au nord de paris que le
village olympique aurait dû voir le jour
mais l'aménagement de ce site des
batignolles reste toujours programmée
c'est d'abord un parc des logements
autant au détail près je ne sais pas
mais certainement avoir de logement
important et puis également des
activités les équipements des bureaux tu
même chose pour le centre aquatique
d'aubervilliers il est maintenu même si
l'on a un peu de mal à imaginer ce que
sera ici une piscine dernier cri ce sera
le même projet ça sera les deux bassins
olympiques et le bassin de plongeon
pas de problème non plus pour la base
nautique de vaires sur marne à l'est de
paris avec ou changer au on continuera
d'y ramener et c'était prévu on ira
pédaler au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
mais en revanche la plupart des grands
équipements olympiques sont annulés à
l'image du superdome sorte de palais
omnisports il devait relier paris et la
banlieue nord en permettant de jeter des
passerelles au dessus du périphérique
tout le quartier de la chapelle devait
en profiter si rien n'est fait il va
rester tel qu'il est bien mal en point
autre actualité de cette journée les
feux de forêt à l'heure où les incendies
repartent un pyromane a été condamné à
quatre ans de prison ferme dans le var
il s'agit d'un ancien sapeur-pompier
volontaire de 56 ans il avait été repéré
par des témoins yannick aroussi emmanuel
zini c'était jeudi dernier en fin
d'après midi
roger facchini et ses hommes sont les
premiers sur le départ de feu il a
démarré grâce à leur intervention le
foyer au coeur du massif forestier vite
noyé la catastrophe est évitée
bilan quelques dizaines de mètres carrés
calcinés et une rencontre très suspecte
le gars en question et les sortir de son
véhicule il m'a ignoré combattants j'ai
relevé la police
l'homme interpellé par les gendarmes a
été jugé hier en comparution immédiate
roger isler à 56 ans pompier volontaire
il ya une quinzaine d'années
contraint à la démission à cause de son
alcoolisme il a invoqué pour sa défense
une maladresse avec une cigarette à ce
que malheureusement il était sous
l'empiré d'un état alcoolique qu'il a
effectivement allumé sa cigarette et que
je sais pas ce qui lui est passé par la
tête
il réfléchira en cellule condamné à
quatre ans de prison faire une sanction
exemplaire apprécié par le maire de la
commune qui s'était constitué partie
civile le tribunal ben
ne sera pas le crime jour ce qui nous
donne satisfaction
je fais partie de ceux qui pensent que
les personnes qui agissent telle somme
doit être puni et sévèrement punis
l'homme est également soupçonné dans un
autre départ de feu ce qu'il nie
totalement avec cette condamnation la
justice a certainement voulu frapper les
esprits en ce début de saison des
incendies
le succès de la privatisation de gaz de
france quelques trois millions deux cent
mille particuliers ont souscrit à
l'offre de l'état 22% du capital du
gazier était vendu vous le savez
l'opération devrait rapporter 4
milliards et demi d'euros qui seront
affectés à l'entreprise d'une part au
désendettement de l'état et au
financement de l'innovation industrielle
d'autre part première cotation demain à
midi économie encore avec le classement
des 500 plus grandes fortunes de france
il est réalisé comme chaque année par
l'hebdomadaire challenges numéro un
bernard arnault président du groupe lvmh
avec un patrimoine estimé à 14,3
milliards d'euros vincent fourcade
jean-jacques le garrec bernard arnault
un prince du luxe aujourd'hui sacré roi
des affaires 8on dior ou encore kenzo
propriété de bernard arnault il possède
le premier groupe mondial de luxe lvmh
il est maintenant l'homme le plus riche
de france sa fortune des passerelles et
14 milliards d'euros
à titre de comparaison c'est suffisant
pour s'offrir 56 airbus à 3 81 25 stade
de france ou encore quatre porte avions
charles de gaulle pour la première fois
il monte sur la plus haute marche du
podium et détrône liliane bettencourt
propriétaire de l'oréal avec plus de 11
milliards d'euros
elle reste tout de même la femme la plus
riche de france numéro 3 gérard mulliez
et sa famille propriétaires du groupe
auchan 10 milliards tout rond les trois
vainqueurs du classement annuel des 500
français les plus riches et ce constat
il est de plus en plus dures d'intégrer
ce top 500 de fortune minimum pour
intégrer le classement de challenges
il est passé de veufs 15 millions il a à
peu près dix ans à 40 millions d'euros
effectivement bon je tire c'est une
progression qui va largement au delà de
ce qu'est la progression du pib
l'inflation
à l'évidence mais même très fortunés ces
français sont encore loin de pouvoir
rivaliser avec les plus riches de la
planète comme par exemple bill gates
fondateur de microsoft il possède à lui
seul plus de 37 milliards d'euros
c'est toujours le record à battre santé
pour réaliser des économies la sécurité
sociale et le gouvernement s'attaque au
conditionnement des médicaments une
boîte au lieu de trois pour les longues
maladies ou les maladies chroniques
l'objectif est de réduire les marges
gagné par les pharmaciens 180 millions
d'euros pourrait être ainsi économisé
sophie rodier à la location hypertension
diabète ostéoporose
aujourd'hui tous ces médicaments doivent
être renouvelés chaque mois à partir
d'août les pharmaciens pourront délivrer
des boîtes contenant trois mois de
traitement
selon le gouvernement cette mesure
permettrait à la sécurité sociale
d'économiser 180 millions d'euros par an
d'ici à 2007
mais pour les pharmaciens c'est une
fausse bonne idée je pense que les
patients ont besoin de rentrer dans le
voir leur pharmacien de rentrer dans la
pharmacie de poser des questions et
s'ils prennent l'habitude de s'y rendent
moins souvent
je pense que le traitement frappa fera
pas très bien suivi
principal motif d'insatisfaction pour
les pharmaciens leur marge sur les
médicaments vont diminuer
le système français est telle que plus
le prix du médicament est élevé ben
ouais la barge et est importante on
gagne moins sur une boîte à 30 euros que
sur trois boîtes à 10 euros donc le
pharmacien d'un arbre et d'argent et
donc ça ferait des économies
de ce point de vue là par ailleurs les
pharmaciens tous 53 centimes d'euros par
boîte vendue cette nouvelle mesure
risquent donc de représenter pour eux un
manque à gagner certain nos informations
en bref à l'étranger d'abord neuf ans
après la fin de la guerre en
ex-yougoslavie ce nouveau pas dans la
traque de radovan karadzic inculpé de
génocide pour ses crimes présumés en
bosnie et notamment le massacre de
srebrenica et bien l'otan a arrêté son
fils vous l'avez aperçu âgé de 32 ans et
qui pourrait détenir des informations
sur la localisation de son père aux
etats unis une journaliste va faire
quatre mois de prison pour avoir refusé
de révéler ses sources
en france c'est un droit là bas
c'est un délit il s'agit de judith
miller qui travaille pour le new york
times la justice américaine recherche le
responsable d'une fuite sur l'identité
d'un agent de la cia
l'un des collègues masculins et judith
miller n'a pas eu le même courage relax
et fait lui de donner l'information pour
éviter l'incarcération sport le tour de
france étape marquée par une chute
collective sur les routes glissantes de
lorraine victoire de l'italien bernucci
lance amstrong est toujours en jaune
nathanaël de rincquesen emmanuel bec
avec son cocker et souvenirs groggy
christophe mengin ressemble plus à un
boxeur qu'un coureur du tour de france
pourtant cet après midi à nancy
le français a longtemps cru pouvoir
emporter la 6e étape 180 kilomètres
d'échappée
jusqu'à ce virage un peu serré et
beaucoup trop mouillé quelques centaines
de mètres avant l'arrivée un passage
piéton et mangin voit s'envoler ses
rêves de victoire
il n'est pas le seul ça je suis
déstabilise tous ses poursuivants
en quelques secondes les sprinteurs du
peloton termine les uns sur les autres
battue j'ai tapé je sais pas ce qui
manque pas grand chose pour la gagne il
ne fallait pas tomber
lorenzo bernucci est le premier surpris
de se retrouver seul face à la ligne
l'italien ne se fait pas prier pour
remporter sa première victoire d'étape
sur le tour et pendant que la femme kong
continue de voir la vie en jaune
marc madiot le directeur sportif de
christophe mengin broie du noir
extrêmement déçu pour son coureur et
pour son équipe
on a subi
avant de refermer ce journal un dernier
détour par londres nous allons retrouver
laurent boussier mais juste avant une
image que nous venons de recevoir
l'image de l'explosion images tournées
quelques secondes après l'explosion du
bus et qui donne une idée de la violence
de la déflagration de la panique aussi
bien sûr qui s'est emparée des habitants
une image amateur tournée via un
téléphone portable laurent londres se
prépare ce soir un retour à la normale
oui absolument un retour à la normale
avec la réouverture de une ou deux
lignes de bus de métros pardon les
autres restent fermés toutes les lignes
et les endroits où il y a eu des
explosions sont considéré maintenant
comme des scènes d'investigation sommes
des lieux d'investigation pour la police
criminelle sont tout à fait bouclé par
contre bonne nouvelle également
normalement demain l'ensemble du réseau
de bus devraient être réorganisée
devrait être réouvert et londoniens dont
certains ne viendront pas travailler
parce que la police a demandé
et encore une fois de limiter les
déplacements les londoniens retrouveront
l'ensemble de leur bus
et puis ce soir il ya encore beaucoup
beaucoup de trafic beaucoup beaucoup
d'encombrements à beaucoup de bouchons à
la sortie de la ville
merci laurent et puis je vous rappelle
que le bilan que nous donnait nicolas
sarkozy après une conversation après son
homologue ministre de l'intérieur
britannique tout à l'heure cinquante
morts et 300 blessés dont 50 dans un
état grave après ces attentats donc à
londres c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de l'avoir suivi tout de suite la météo
isabelle martinet pour un route valérie
maurice
20h55 la télé de sébastien autour de la
carrière bien sûr de patrick sébastien
23h15 campus guillaume durand 12h50
dernier journal laurence piquette
dès 6h30 du matin autour de william
leymergie à 13 heures benoît duquesne à
20 heures et le week end on retrouve
béatrice schönberg en ski sur une image
traditionnelle de ce début d'été les
images du premier lâcher de taureaux de
la san firmin
ils étaient douze ce matin dans les rues
de pampelune accompagnés par les
centaines de coureurs comme chaque année
des late show aussi dans ce vol sur
l'homme que pour l'animal ils vont durer
une semaine
pas de blessés aujourd'hui en tout cas à
lundi
à